I've got three rectangles here and I
also have their their dimensions I have
their height and their width in fact
this one right here has the same height
and width so this is actually a square
so let's think about how much space they
each take up on my screen and since
we're doing everything in terms of
meters since all of the dimensions are
in meters I'm going to measure the area
in terms of square meters so let's see
how many square meters I can fit onto
this yellow rectangle without going
outside of its boundary and without
overlapping so I can fit one square
meter remember a square meter is just a
square where its length is one meter and
its width is one meter so that's one
square meter two three four or five five
and six square meters so we see here
that the area that the area is 6 square
meters area is equal to 6 square square
meters but something might be jumping
out at you did I really have to sit and
count 1 2 3 4 5 6 you might have
recognized that I could view this as
really two groups of three let me make
that very clear so for example I could
view this as one group of three one
group of three and then another group of
three now how did I get groups of three
well that's because the width here is
three meters so I could put three I
could put three square meters
side-by-side and how did I get the two
groups well it's two meters this has the
length of two meters so another way that
I could have essentially counted these
six things is I could have said look I
have a length of two meters so I'm going
to have two groups of three I'm going to
have two groups of three so I could
multiply two times three two times three
two times two of my groups of three and
I would have gotten six and I would have
gotten six so I could and you might say
hey wait is this just a coincidence that
if I took
the the height or if I took the length
and I multiplied it by the width that I
get the same thing as its area and no
it's not because when you took the the
length you essentially said well how
many rows do I have and then you say
when you multiply it by the width you're
saying well how many squares do I or how
many of these how many of these square
meters can I fit into a row so this is a
really a quick way of counting how many
of these square meters you have so you
could say that two meters
multiplied by three meters multiplied by
three meters is equal to 6 square meters
is equal to 6 square square meters now
you might say hey I'm not sure if that
always applies let's see if it applies
to these other rectangles right over
here so based on what we just saw let's
take the length 4 meters let's take the
length 4 meters and multiplied by the
width and multiplied by 2 meters 2
meters now 4 times 2 is 8 so this should
give us 8 square 8 square meters let's
see if this is actually the case so 1 2
3 4 5 and you see it's going in the
right direction 5 6 7 7 & 8 so the area
of this rectangle is indeed 8 square
meters and you could view this as 4
groups of 2 so you could literally view
this as 4 groups of 2 that's where the 4
times 2 comes from so you could view it
as 4 groups of 2 like this or you could
view it as 2 groups of 4 so one group of
4 right over here so you could view this
as 2 times 4 and then two groups two
groups of 4 I want to draw it a little
bit cleaner now you could probably
figure out what the area of this
rectangle is actually a square has the
same length and the same width we
multiply the length 3 meters times the
width so times
three meters to get three times three is
nine nine square nine square meters nine
square meters and let's verify it again
just to feel really good about this
multiplying the dimensions of these
rectangles so we have one two three four
five six seven eight and nine
so it matches up we figure out how many
square meters can we can we cover this
thing with without overlapping without
going into the boundaries we get the
exact same thing as if we multiplied
three times three if we multiply the
length times the width in meters